in the last video we we talked a little
bit about or at least potentially
starting a cupcake factory but this is a
major investment that I'm I'm thinking
about making so I'd like at minimum I
made a spreadsheet here in Excel and
it's available at at khanacademy.org
/downloads slash cupcakes XLS and if you
just click slash here you'll see
everything in the download directory but
I'm gonna start putting more stuff there
so I encourage you to play with it but
this is essentially it'll do all the
math for us that we did in the last
video so you know the investment in the
factory let's say you know in the real
world once I actually got bids from
contractors and things like that ends up
costing 1.1 million dollars the annual
capacity is a million cupcakes per year
the cost per cupcake let's say I don't
know input cost went up for whatever
reason I you know now that I have a
computer doing the math for me I can
deal with a little bit funnier numbers
so let's take say it's a dollar five the
price charged per cupcake is two dollars
or actually it could be anything right
and so this is going to be an input
field and right now it says two dollars
and this is let's say this is what we
assume is how many cupcakes we sell and
in this scenario this is the income
statement at least as far as we get to
the operating income line and so you
know it calculates that you have two
million of revenue and notice what
happens when I change it if I sell my
cupcakes for a dollar fifty per cupcake
then I only have 1.5 million so it
actually computes what we need it to
compute it computes the cost of goods
sold if I change the number of cupcakes
let's see if instead of a million if I
sell 500,000 it calculates everything
accordingly and all of these scenarios
it tells me my operating income and if
you go a little bit lower it tells me
well capacity utilization that's just
how many cupcakes I sold divided by how
many I could make so that's 50%
utilization and then my return on asset
is my operating income divided by my
initial investment right so this is 275
thousand divided by 1.1 it was a minus
25 so there's actually a bad outcome so
in the last one I touched on a little
bit that you know the real lever the
real lever that
I as a as the owner of my cupcake
factory can change his price and then
obviously if I charge a lower price more
people are going to want to buy my
cupcakes and if I charge a higher price
fewer people although you know there are
some things that when you charge a
higher price people think it must be
better so maybe they want it or they you
know they want to show off to their
friends and you know look at this
expensive cupcake that I eat and it's
kind of a status symbol but you know for
the most part the lower you the price
the more you sell and now we can
actually figure out under what
combinations am I going to make certain
amounts of money so if I charge a dollar
fifty per cupcake and I'm only able to
sell 500,000 cupcakes I'm going to take
a loss per year of two hundred
seventy-five thousand if I sell them for
a dollar seventy-five and if I sell I
don't know seven hundred thousand
cupcakes I'm almost at break you and I
lose so let's say I have to do a dollar
eighty five here in this situation I
actually make money I have a five
percent return on asset and just so you
know this is a major investment that I'm
making 1.1 million dollars I actually
want to make sure I understand all of
the scenarios of price and sales so what
I did is actually used Excel to do a
sensitivity study so what I did here is
I put all of the let me just go to that
part of the spreadsheet and I encourage
you to play with this because it's
interesting and it shows you that even a
fairly simple business you can do a lot
of analysis and if you're if you're in
high school or in middle school this
could actually be a fun I don't know if
they allow this type of thing for
science projects but go to a local
business and kind of analyze the
business in a hundred different ways and
actually if you watch the probability
videos I do all those things on plus a
plus all processes and things like that
and you can analyze a business and do
Excel spreadsheets and you'll probably
end up winning the the state science
fair you get to call it a math project
or engineering project but anyway here I
wanted to figure out what is my return
on asset so essentially you know the the
the my operating profit divided by my
initial investment depending on the
different prices I might charge and the
mut at the different quantities and here
it's kind of hard to visualize so I
graphed it as a three-dimensional
surface 3d alright so you see here if I
charge two dollars eighty and I only
sell 300,000 then this
my return on asset right here and I'll
and this curve is actually the zero
curve right so this is actually my
breakeven right here so any point along
this break on the along this curve right
here I'm breakeven so if I met two
dollars eighty per cupcake and I only
sell 300,000 I'm breakeven or if I'm
let's see what is this right here if I
sell a dollar sixty per cupcake but I
sell on if I sell like nine hundred
thousand then I'm also breakeven so this
is this is my breakeven curve this is
what I want to avoid everything here is
in the negative right this is this
according to the legend - 50 percent to
zero percent return so here I'm losing
money and I would color it in if I
wasn't in Excel mode but if I only if I
charged a dollar sixty per cupcake and I
only sell four hundred thousand cupcakes
I'm going to have a negative return and
we can actually figure it out in that
little worksheet I just did but anyway
this is fun to look at and I encourage
you to play with it and actually shows
you that it's you know it's a fairly you
know interesting and sophisticated thing
that you have these two variables that
change and even though this is kind of a
lot as simple as a business can get and
then you can only imagine what happens
when you start varying the other
parameters but these are the two big
ones so let's say you know when I come
out the gate I I want everyone in town
to taste my cupcakes because I think
once they once they taste it they'll
realize that that they're delicious and
by the way I've also learned from from
the cigarette companies and I put
nicotine in my cupcake so I think people
will become addicted to it so what I do
is I want to charge a relatively low
price for it so let's say I do come out
the gate at oh I don't know a dollar
seventy five and that's a very cheap
price for cupcakes and there's actually
no cupcake producers in this town right
now so I just sell out one two three I
just sell out of cupcakes and so I'm
making $200,000 per year and that's an
18 percent return on asset and you know
a lot of people would be happy with that
but like a you know I'm I'm leaving
money on the table because I'm selling
out of my cupcakes so what happens if I
raise my price a little bit I should
just you know I should just I'm fully
utilized right I have a hundred percent
utilization so it makes sense for me to
see if there's any you know maybe there
there's some people who want cupcakes
who can't get them because I can't
produce that many so let me raise my
price a little bit let me say I raise it
to a dollar eighty five and at a dollar
eighty five it still turns out that I'm
selling a million cupcakes in a year now
I was right I was leaving money on the
table now I'm making 300 thousand a year
so I you know this seems like a good
idea I want to see kind of how much
people are willing to pay so let's say I
raise the price to two dollars but in
that scenario two dollars it starts to
get a little pricey for people it just
kind of little sticker shock maybe I
should have done a dollar ninety-nine
and so I don't sell a million I sell 950
thousand so it's only kind of that you
know there was maybe 50,000 people on
the margin who'd said hey you know I'd
buy at a dollar 85 but I'm not willing
to buy it at two dollars but this still
works out right I'm still making more
money even though I'm selling fewer
cupcakes because I'm charging so much
more per cupcake and I'm making a 30
percent 37 percent return and let's say
you know I keep figuring this out and
let's say I figure that the optimal
point is me charging $3 per cupcake and
at $3 per cupcake I'm able to sell
750,000 cupcakes and I make 962 thousand
a year and I have a huge return on asset
88% imagine a business you know or some
investment we get 88% of your money
every year so that's all in good and I'm
you know I'm driving a Bentley and you
know and I have the biggest house on a
hill in town and all of that but other
people say hey all Sal's doing is making
cupcakes I can make cupcakes too and I
have some money too to build a factory
and you know this this is a better
return on investment than the stock
market or anything else that I know of
so I'm also going to get into into the
into the the cupcake factory business
and so here and this is the second
worksheet in the spreadsheet
the second worksheet right here so let's
say what was my I I was at 1/3 I don't
if you could see this maybe I should
zoom in a little bit let me see if I can
there you go so the same thing so I said
$3 and what I say 750,000 cupcakes and
my cost was a dollar or five so I was
making nine hundred sixty two thousand
but then Imran and just so you're
curious why I wasn't recording videos
for the last two weeks actually Imran is
the name of my son and and and he came
in to the world two weeks ago and so I
think it makes sense to name a cupcake
store after him but let's say he comes
in and he's like well you know I don't
tired of getting an allowance from dad I
also want to produce cupcakes and and he
actually has more money because his
grandma gave him I don't know more money
because she likes him more than then
maybe her son and so he has a
million-five to invest because he's like
wow this is such a good investment let
me put more money into it 1.5 million
and he builds a factory that can produce
2 million cupcakes a year and he's like
you know what
and also it's a more efficient factory
so it actually uses a little little a
little less electricity and it wastes a
less cream and and and and frosting and
and I guess nicotine as well so the cost
per cupcake the cost per cupcake is less
and he decides to undercut his his
father and so he charges 2 dollars 90
per cupcake and when he charges two
hours and I bury well you know everyone
just kind of runs to him because his
cupcakes are just as good there really
wasn't much of a barrier so let's say he
sells he sells 500,000 cupcakes and then
I'm only selling 250,000 at $3 there's
just some people who who like my
cupcakes so I'm I'm pretty much almost
breakeven and you know I say well you
know these are my my diehard fans and so
to benefit them these guys aren't going
to go anywhere else I'm going to raise
my prices a little bit just because I
know that these guys like me and at
least in that situation I'm cutting a
profit but then I say well you know what
this isn't a good state of affairs he
took all my business and I actually want
you to to notice something right here
what happened immediately I was making
an 88% return on my money
right and just when this Imran comes in
and he enters into the space all of a
sudden what what is the what is the
return
earng he's he's only running at 25
percent utilization but his return on
asset has gone down to 20 and because
he's at that low utilization his return
on assets going down to 20 percent and
then my return on assets gone down to 1%
so there's a general theme here is when
you know someone is doing really well
and getting a really great return it
attracts competition it attracts
capacity right and if there's enough
demand to satiate that new capacity
maybe they will get a better return but
in general over time if there's a very
favorable return more and more
competition will enter the market and
actually I've run out of time in this
video in the next video I'll talk about
more scenarios with competition see you
soon